hi
so today i want to talk about my
favorite
neuroscience
philosophy
psychology books
that i have read the last year or reread
the last year
so the first one i want to talk about is
the book by matthew walker called why we
sleep and i personally really enjoyed
this book because
i worked in the sleep laboratory at the
donders neuroscience center in the
netherlands
and i was just really excited to see a
book
that talks about the importance of sleep
not only for your body but also for your
mind and your brain functioning
so the book first goes into that if we
don't sleep enough what kind of adverse
health effects it has on our body and
that actually our lifespan
decreases significantly so i think
already from the first chapter we can
see
why it's so important to sleep but then
he goes on
by giving this really strong
research as to the
benefits of sleep so for example sleep
can increase your memory or your
memory retention is better to say
so when we don't sleep actually our
short-term memories that we've created
during the day usually are not well
transferred to our long-term memory
so
one really good example is when we drink
a lot this not only has adverse effects
on our body but also on our sleep and
that's why sometimes we see that when
people drink a lot that they forget
everything they did during the night
that they drank
and he also goes into how
an increase in sleep or a better
sleeping pattern can actually help with
creativity so they showed these students
different type of math problems and they
didn't know how to solve it but after
they slept
they were able to solve these problems
or if they didn't sleep they weren't
able to solve these problems
and personally i i was just really
excited to see
that the importance of sleep is finally
recognized within
wider pop culture especially because
we've seen these kind of
hustle culture videos all the time of
people that wake up at crazy or early
hours
in the morning 6 a.m 5 a.m 4 00 am even
and they then established that they're
super productive by doing this and i do
believe that these people are probably
really productive by doing this but for
the general population this is just not
a good idea because you will get a
decrease in your sleep and this decrease
in sleep leads to all these adverse
effects that matthew walker talks about
so i would really recommend to
read this book if you're also interested
in sleep or
if you're interested in the science of
sleep but also if you're just interested
in how to optimize your sleeping pattern
it i think it's a really good book
to start with so the second book i want
to talk about is the book by victor
franco and it's called the man's search
for meaning and it's i think
one of the books i re-read almost every
two years or so
because every time you read it you
discover something new or something
profound that's really important for
your life at the moment
so the book is written by viktor frankl
who is this nazi camp survivor or this
concentration camp survivor in
germany and he survived while surviving
this camp he thought about the
difference what makes
people want to live and survive the camp
or what makes people want to give up and
that's kind of the start of or his
premises for logotherapy which is this
really common therapy method even
nowadays in psychology
towards searching for your own
individual
sense of meaning in your life
so in the book he kind of has these
three messages which i will go over real
quick
so his first message is kind of
that in order to survive and in his case
that was the concentration camp one
needs to surrender or accept one's own
death
and i think this is kind of in the line
of stoicism where you really come eye to
eye with your own
death and by doing that you can kind of
accept it and
move on in that sense and i think
especially for him during that time this
is of course
was of course extremely important
because he saw so much death all around
him and in order to
be able to survive what he did he really
had to come eye to eye with his own
imminent death perhaps and even that of
his friends in the world
and all that surrounding him
and
i think for us nowadays this is
quite a bit easier perhaps to imagine
because the world has been changing so
much
lately and i think
to accept death as not
a friend but perhaps something that's
just always present
you can come
more in terms and grips with also life
so i think this is a really nice message
that he
said in his book
and afterwards he goes on to that one's
goal in life is to search for one's own
meaning so he doesn't really believe in
the traditional sense
anymore that god has bestowed a meaning
upon us or that the outside world
determines what our meaning is but he
says it's an active job of men to search
for their own meaning in their lives
and this can also change so for example
if you're right now a student perhaps
the meaning that you find right now is
just learning
going to school
finding friends etc etc but perhaps when
you grow up a little bit and maybe you
become a mother or a father then the
meaning of your life will change it will
become taking care of your children or
being the best parent this child might
have
and in such a way it's really an active
job for
humans
to keep searching for our own meaning
and our own reason for existence
because the world is not gonna give it
to us it's for us to decide
and to think about
and he goes on to
explain that people that don't actively
think about this
will go on to kind of get this
sense of hopelessness or this sense of
no direction and i think in the 21st
century this is becoming more and more
important because we kind of see that
the world is changing so fast around us
that it's sometimes hard to really
understand
what is my meaning and what am i doing
in this world right now so i think
reading this book would be really
beneficial if you're struggling with
something like that at the moment and
the third thing he talks about a lot is
fear
and how actually
by coming eye to eye with our real fears
we can kind of get rid of them so a good
example i think
is for example if you're really afraid
of
stuttering when you're presenting
sometimes the fear is not even for the
presenting or the people around you but
it's actually a fear of the
stuttering itself so you're afraid you
will stutter and thus you will stutter
and by just coming eye to eye with the
fact that you sometimes stutter and just
accepting this the stuttering can go
away that's kind of the idea he goes
into
and i think this is really profound and
this is a real interesting technique
that is sometimes also used in
psychology by kind of coming eye to eye
with your fears
so yeah i would really recommend to
read this book it has changed
my view a lot of
more in a philosophical sense of what
we're here to do on earth
because i do sometimes struggle with
meaning and what's the meaning
of life and these kind of things and i
think
searching for this and thinking about
this
sometimes not all the time is really
good and i think it's really profound
the things he discusses in his book
so the third book i want to talk about
is by oliver sax
the man who mistook his wife for a hat
and i recently reread it because there
has been a documentary about his life
which came out i think in 2019
but i watched it last month or so so i
decided to reread some of his books
because he was kind of my inspiration of
going into neuroscience and to go into
the fields of computational neuroscience
in the end so his book goes into these
different types of neurological
disorders and it starts with this really
interesting example of this man who
mistook his wife for a hat
or who mistook the hat for his wife
and i think the interesting thing that
sex does by
going over all his stories is he doesn't
really describe his stories from a
really clinical perspective but he
really tries to go into
or look through the eyes of his patients
so he describes every
disorder in a sense of how the patients
view the world and how in a sense they
also have a bigger picture of the world
sometimes
and i think this is really nice because
he kind of destroys the image of
what normal brain functioning is or what
a patient is
because some of his patients really
don't see
themselves as patients they really
view the world just in a different
manner than us and sometimes an even
wider manner so he shows how for some
patients their disorder actually helps
them to create art or to see
life in a different way
and i think this is really nice and even
for me right now i'm working with
psychiatric data and we're really
thinking about normal brain functioning
and what's a normal brain versus an
atypical brain
and i think reading his book i kind of
really need to
keep reminding myself that what we think
is normal is not necessarily what our
brain says is normal or how we view the
world but more what society deems as
normal
so yeah i think if you are thinking of
going into neuroscience or following
this topic
or you find something like this
interesting then i think it's a really
good book to start with and i would also
recommend to read all his other works
because all of his
books are written in this really easy
accessible style so even if you're not
familiar with
neuroscience or psychology i think
everyone can read it and learn something
from it
yeah hopefully you've found some books
or some inspiration for your next
book to read and if you have some
recommendations for me as well as to
what you really like to read within
neuroscience
philosophy psychiatry
put them down below i would love i would
love to read them and uh yeah see you
next time bye
[Music]
you